plusieurs centaines de milliers de
personnes ont défilé aujourd'hui à Paris
à l'occasion de la Gay Pride musique est
faite bien sûr mais aussi revendication
40 ans après le combat homosexuel pour
l'égalité continue Aurélia BR et Patrick
bmuli il n revient pas mais c'est bien
elle l'a Minelli la star américaine a
demandé elle-même à être présente pour
l'ouverture de cette marche 40 ans après
le début de la lutte des
homosexuels dans la foule des centaines
de milliers de personnes G lesbienne
bisexuel transsexuel et hétéro mélange
des genres pour moment
d'euphorie le but c'est de montrer qu'on
peut manifester de façon joyeuse tout
simplement ah bah on se lâche on rigole
on explose nos droits c'est tout c'est
notre
journée à quand la
hopride pour que les ééros puissent
s'intégrer parmi les
gay fait ne fait pas oublier les raisons
de cette
marche Iran Yémen Soudan Afghanistan
comme le rappelle ce char dans plusieurs
pays les homosexuels sont parfois
condamnés à
mort en France la situation est bien
différente mais aujourd'hui le mot
d'ordre c'est
l'égalité nous sommes toujours des
scitoyens des citoyens de seconde zone
moi je vis avec mon ami depuis
maintenant 17 ans et ben j'ai pas le
droit de me marier avec lui alors que je
l'aime et qu'il m'aime j'ai pas envie
d'avoir d'enfant mais si j'avais envie
d'en avoir et je peux pas l'adopter cet
après-midi beaucoup de parents homo sont
d'ailleurs venus avec leurs enfants nous
on a une grande joie d'avoir des enfants
et c'est tellement injuste ça changer un
jour et si les revendications sont
sérieuses une fois encore cette année
l'humour était un invité
d'honneur